[موسيقى]
لذلك نحن هنا في متحف التقنيات
لأنني ألهمني هذا
الموقع وهذا موقع خاص حقًا
كما لو كنت دائمًا
مهتمًا بالأشياء التقنية والسيارات حتى يكون لديك
مشروع فيديو هنا في هذا
الموقع فهو مميز جدًا لـ
كان الجزء الأكثر خصوصية بالنسبة لي هو
الجزء الموجود على الجانب
الأيسر خارج الجدار ،
وكان ذلك جنونيًا للغاية
لكل الأشياء التي تلعب
معًا الريح والطقس
وكان ذلك مثيرًا للغاية
[موسيقى]
لقد كان كثيرًا من المرح  أنت تعرف أنك تعرف
أنك إذا نظرت هنا مع
كل هذه
السيارات التاريخية والدراجات ، فإن ركوب الدراجات
يشبه تجاوز العقبات على
دراجة نارية ، وهذا
ما يجعلني فقط التحديات
الجديدة والحيل الجديدة التي يمكنني تجربتها وهي جديدة
تجربة كل يوم